um how does the because obviously we're
in LA and uh you know the politics of
Los Angeles are widely spoken about
um uh you you obviously are from a
certain area in Dallas and represent
certain something from Dallas what is
the difference because when we think of
like LA and like Crips and bloods out
here there's a lot of [__] sets that be
for [__] sets and the politics are just
once you dive in like it's if you're not
from La once you come here and you learn
everything you're like whoa yeah what's
it like out there so like honestly
epitome is watered down like it's out
here
I feel like it's basic step behind this
[__] more for sure but they're out in
Dallas it's like you gotta this is not
what it is it's not what it is yeah you
know what I'm saying like yeah you got a
bunch of people that claim this claim it
but I feel like I think more people
fight for their hoods then they they six
like I got a one of my partners is blood
he a [__] you see what I'm saying but
allegedly
yeah allegedly so but yeah
yeah I don't know it's just it's
different yeah it's different that's
good because like out here like you know
you can't you couldn't wear [__]
Houston Astros hat out here I told that
I was like hey bro I tell everybody
don't wear Yankees don't wear Astros I
mean really you can't wear many hats if
you're not gonna be
like if you're going to be in the valley
or like your show or something Mercy is
different if you like go hang out to go
eat like in la la you got to kind of
watch your uh fitted Choice listen I
mean it's different when you can you can
you can vouch behind your seat you know
what I'm saying so Nick somebody might
try to g-check you you just got to be
you gotta say do you have like big
homies in L.A I make things happening
with people as we speak I don't know
what I'm saying but that's the right
thing to do yeah I mean but it's like
it's different when a [__] say oh you
gotta check in and because that sounds a
little like yeah like no I'm not
checking in nowhere but it man if you
hear me like hey man I [__] with what
you got going I see what you're trapping
with me it's different it's about the
approach it's different and so we had a
couple people do that so we'll be in the
process that's happening with those
people right now uh any L.A hip hop
you're listening to or anybody who you
[__] with out here uh [__] Greedo just
did his house arrest time prison
sentence out there man I need to he did
and I [__] agree though and I need to
apologize to him right now on your
podcast because he sent me a song that
he wanted me to do I think he wanted me
to be on his next project and I ended up
getting a whole new phone so I lost
remember even I still had his Instagram
but it was just like I kind of had
forgot that he even it happens but when
you just said it I was like Credo damn
you smile here damn we were supposed to
do a song together
so yeah I apologize to you my boy and if
you still want me to do that song matter
of fact I'm a team when we leave here
um you obviously dropped the deluxe to
your album which in my opinion is one of
the best projects of the Year appreciate
you appreciate it
um what how I mean obviously you're on
the road right now but you also just
were in Arizona working on new music
yeah
um so what is the are we getting some
new [__] soon obviously yeah you just
put a single out uh with uh yeah yeah
that one going crazy but you know we're
on tour right now so we already we just
scheduled out to mix Four single drops
all hard man you know after that we come
with like an EP or something I'm not I'm
not changing nothing why don't y'all do
it like a joint album oh that's on the
way
that's gonna be the like I just started
the label 600 entertainment yeah so
that's gone I'm gonna need a chain two
for sure all my people got them I was
like so I got you how did you guys link
up we actually made it senior year high
school so I got kicked out of three
schools my senior year oh wow you was
one of them I was I was a football
player but I had got big hit it like I
had offers everywhere yeah like that's
where I ended up having to go to a Juco
because
my head got so big you were getting in
trouble I got kicked I swung on the
coach and uh my first school oh [__] I
kicked out ended up going to like this
little school in the country play like
four Games took them to the playoffs
right after the football season they
turned out to be very much racist
and yeah so I ended up getting kicked
out of that school the school was racist
yeah in Texas no way
I'm kidding yeah yeah like I'm talking
about like drove around with Confederate
flags on the back of their trucks so I
lived in Florida for a few years and I
didn't even know like I'm from Arizona
which is like there's a certain element
of white trash out there but it ain't
like it's like tweaker like biker gang
white trash it ain't like redneck white
trash right yeah so when I moved to
Florida
like um
I I there was a whole new white trash
introduced into my life and it was like
Southern or white trash and these guys
who got like the South will rise again
flags
and I was just like these people are
still oh yeah yeah it was bad they they
I got kicked out of the school for my
safety if that is or anything what the
[__] yeah what's the name of uh
I left so I when I lived in Florida I
drove
from Phoenix to Tampa Tampa to Phoenix
and I was with my boys who were Brown
and my homie from Houston was like
East Texas there's a town he said
whatever you do don't stop there I think
it starts with a v
is it uh sorry I would have thought they
was talking about time
valdi Texas valdi Texas
but I heard that like in Texas there's
some cities that are like [__] yeah
they're just openly
Ellis County
is that what you said Tyler Tyler said
yeah yeah they they out there still
trying to hang folks oh my God yeah like
it's going down out there the KKK is
very active in Texas I've heard but up
there still be having meats and [__] for
that yeah it's so crazy because Texas is
one of the let's it reminds me of
Florida in terms of like
you could be like one town over from
like some real lit racist like [__] but
then you go to the next town and it's
like and the white people is at the
black people barbecues that's what I'm
saying yeah yeah cause like man like
when you go to Houston you're like oh
this is a Melting Pot everyone kind of
gets along like you know yeah I went to
Dallas once I told you I went to Dallas
WrestleMania had a good time but it was
it wasn't my favorite city but I feel
like I did I went I went with the wrong
people gotta go with me yeah yeah I
definitely was like with you know guys
where I was just like
I was like these places are trash
like what gotta go with me and then we
try to get into a spot was there a strip
club called onyx
back in the day
yeah yeah they like blue cheese but it
was like maybe eight years ago right
yeah yeah that was before I was going to
strip clubs or something maybe it was
called Onyx maybe it was called Babylon
maybe it was I don't know but anyway I
[__] try to go yeah it probably was
on it for sure I was just disappointed
with the talent because you had to go to
like uh
really just depending on what you like
but Latin and women of colors ecstasy
non-whites
yeah yeah I see him I see him going
crazy ecstasy I see we take them to Cab
North
he's a man to it by like the third
bottle he's having a great time oh yeah
hey tour is over I'm coming to Texas for
sure we gotta come and hang out
um
also you guys are able to carry guns yes
which is a plus in my opinion yeah but
it's they they pull a lot of little
[__] though so like you you can have
a gun but if you got like they pulled me
over right now I got this with me
because you got the gun it's a problem
it's unlawful care what yes
oh that's crazy you can't you can't be
doing any you can't run a red light why
you got a gun unlawful unlocked so if
you're breaking any other law while you
have a gun it's unlawful I forget you
guys can't smoke weed legally there we
were just we just had a show in San
Antonio and everybody in my car with the
gym but me
for weed my the driver went to jail
because he had he had a gun on him and
he ran a red light boom took him to jail
uh the passenger my little brother
he was a real one you know he yeah he
did what he's supposed to do
he went to jail
um there was another young lady in the
car she had like a little weeding up in
the bottom of her purse went to jail